the los angeles rams getting some
measure of revenge but not much for
losing super bowl 53 to the new england
patriots as sean mcvay said it it did
really
it's really not the same winning in the
regular season against the team that
beat you in the super bowl does not make
it okay you don't get to claim their
trophy you don't get to go steal their
rings
they still won when it mattered most but
it was impressive last night peter king
from the la rams 24-3 victory
over the new england patriots put a fork
in the patriots
and raise the curtains on us for the
next two hours on pft live good morning
peter how are you
good morning mike my biggest question
after last night's game
is very simple if the chargers lost to
the patriots
by 45 points and if
the rams beat the patriots by 21 points
does that mean that if the rams and
chargers played
that the rams would win 66 to nothing
you know i'm not sure but all i can say
is
one team is awful and the other team
killed the team that beat the awful team
so
uh i don't know what to say other than
that couldn't have been a good night
last night for dean spanos
i i can't imagine a bigger point spread
differential for a team especially
four days apart from sunday to thursday
then scoring 45
and then falling all the way down to
three and i joked on
monday that maybe the patriots should
have saved a few of those points that
they scored against the chargers
they just they couldn't make it happen
last night and and credit
more than anything else to the rams
defense a team that we have known
for offense over the last few years
because of sean mcvay the defense put
the clamps
on the patriots suffocating goal lines
stand when the patriots were trying to
make it interesting when it was 17
nothing
and then never let them get close to the
end zone after that and really in the
second half
couldn't get anything going to the point
where cam newton got benched for jared
stidham again it's the second time it's
happened this year
and not a surprise because neither
quarterback could really
make anything happen last night for the
patriots i don't think anybody could
have made anything happen last night for
the patriots against that defense peter
yeah i mean the rams defense look
you know when when brandon staley got
hired by
uh sean mcvay at the beginning of this
season i think everyone said
so what you know nobody cared well
they're getting rid of
wade phillips they're they're bringing
in a young guy
and i mean the reaction around the
league mike
was essentially that oh you know what
sean mcvay wants younger blood
around his team and they not only got
younger blood but they also brought in a
coach
in brendan staley who
essentially has brought what vic fangio
does
in denver and before that in chicago
where
uh staley met up with him and
he's brought that sort of defense which
is
to me a very confusing
looking defense staley takes pride
sort of in in a bit of a different way
but takes pride in exactly what bill
belichick
does with his defense it is a snowflake
it can be different every week
you could see jalen ramsey on the best
receiver on the other team
you could have seen you could see him
playing all over the map
you could see him playing deep he's even
played in the slot this year
so that is what i saw last night the new
england patriots having
no idea how to deal with that defense
and staley by the way now i think has
firmly played himself into contention
for a head coaching job or at least some
head coaching interviews at the end of
the year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports